wir sehen jetzt dass die regierung im
kreml angst hat vor einer und sich
hanowski so deute ich die wiederholten
angriffe auf sie bzw festnahmen es wird
ja julia nicht mal erlaubt für ihren
mann zu demonstrieren das ist ja auch
sozusagen menschen verachten ja also
eine frau hatten ich meine gelegenheit
öffentlich für ihren mann partei zu
ergreifen
sie wird ja gleich beim verlassen der u
bahn schächten norm bei jeder
demonstration weil es die langsam auch
zu einer symbolfigur galionsfigur diese
bewegung geworden ist und noch mehr
werden könnte denn sie ist eine starke
frau eine das hat man ja auch gesehen in
ordnung nach der vergiftung das ist auch
jemand die bereit ist für ihren mann
aber auch für diese idee der
demokratischen gesellschaft sehr viel zu
tun und da hat kreml angst also ich
rechne damit dass es immer wieder
sozusagen einschüchterungsversuche geben
wird ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
kreml jetzt ganz schlimme sachen so
gefängnisstrafen etc sich ausdenken
würde aber gestern wurde sie schon zu
einer geldstrafe verurteilt aus
lächerlichen gründen wie die meisten
gefährten tonne also sie wird ganz
besonders beobachtet um den vergleich
die sich gezogen hat einmal kurz zu
erklären zu das wird lernt ihr an oskar
ja das ist die frau eines ehemaligen
eigentlich eines ehemaligen kandidaten
für die präsidentschaftswahl in
weißrussland dann ist ihr mann und
andere männer sind dann verhaftet worden
und dann ist dort ihren oscar anstelle
ihres mannes angetreten ist inzwischen
eine galionsfigur für den widerstand in
weißrussland leider mit dem
schönheitsfehler hat dass sie nicht dass
wir aus weißrussland sagen wir ganz
vorsichtig heraus produziert worden ist
und jetzt im exil lebt mit ihren kindern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren